في منزل أنثى السنجاب  دق دق الباب
تك تك تك من بالباب
دق الثعلب باب الذئب  *** عانقه وبكل الحب
هيا يا صديقي ساعدني *** لنأكل أبناء السنجاب
شرب الذئب من الترياق *** وبصوت مثل السنجاب
هتف أتيت يا رفاق *** صاحبكم فدعوني أدخل
لا لن نخدع أنت الذئب ***  إذهب اذهب يا كذاب
ما دامت ماما بالخارج  *** لن ندخل أبدا أغراب
في منزل أنثى السنجاب  دق دق الباب
تك تك تك من بالباب؟
صعد الذئب لسطح المنزل ***  من مدخنة البيت سيدخل
أشعل أبناء السنجاب  ***  فيها النار فقفز مهرول
ذئب الغابة يا غدار ***   بالعقل لدينا أفكار
لن نفتح باب المنزل ***    أو ندع غريبا يدخل
اي يا ويلي
في منزل أنثى السنجاب  دق دق الباب
تك تك تك من بالباب؟
نفخ الذئب ونفخ كثير ***   بهواء للرمل مثير
سقط الذئب من الإعياء ***   والثعلب مغموما يسعل
اسمعنا اسمع يا ذئب  ***   هاتفنا صاحبنا الفيل
وسيأتي يخلصنا منكم  ***   ويهز الغابة ويزلزل
في منزل أنثى السنجاب  دق دق الباب